اول ما همم يعني بدات المفاهمه مع منظمه
التجاره سؤال انا نحن لسنا مختصين اللغه
كيف همم سي تنفذ برامج في المنظمات
التجاره ونحن نعتقد انه من حق اللغه
العربيه وهي من الواتساب ان تحذف في جميع
المنظمات بل ان الرهان الكبير الذي نسعى
اليه كيف نستطيع ان نمكن اللغه العربيه في
جميع
التجاره يعني ان تصير في الموقع الرسمي
اللغه موجوده فيهم وفي ان ان يجد العربيه
حاجته بلغته في اي مكان
ليس موجود في جميع المنظمات
[موسيقى]
هذا سقراط من اذاعه 8 هو يعمل في استضيف
قاعده تتحول وقاده الاعمال وقاده الراي
وسولف معهم على المستجدات ومستهدفات رؤيه
السعوديه 20 30 هو الدكتور عبد الله
الوشمي الامين العام المكلف لمجمع الملك
سلمان العالمي للغه العربيه الحلقه مهمه
لكل الغيورين على اللغه العربيه اللي
كانوا يعتقدون بانه الانطلاق السريع
للرؤيا في
بعض المشاريع بعض المسميات المؤتمرات
اللغه التي تستخدم في هذه المؤتمرات
الانفتاح على العالم كل هذا حي ياثر على
لغتنا همم الضيف قاعد يروينا المشروع اللي
يفترض انه يوازن هذه الانطلاقه وهذه
الانفتاح
باعتزاز وحفاظ على لغتنا مو بس كده وانما
ايضا همم خدمتها على مستوى عالمي في
المنظمات الدوليه همم وفي المعاجم همم
العالميه ومع السفارات ومع السفاره ومختلف
المبادرات والبرامج على المسارات الاربعه
اللي هم مركزين عليها وتحدثنا على اهم
اتحقق في كل مسار همم وباذن الله تكون
حلقه تجيب على اهم التساؤلات اللي تخصص
موضوع العلاقه اللغه بالهويه ليش الاطفال
ما همم بعض العلماء ما يشعر بالفخر الا
اذا او طفل يتكلم باللغه
الاجنبيه هل المحتوى اللي تستهلك الاجنبي
مثل الافلام السينما ومنصات المشاهده همم
ممكن نشوفه يوم من الايام مترجم هل هذه من
اولوياتهم هل بيكون عندنا اختبار التوفل
الخاص فينا اللغه العربيه لاي احد يبغى
همم يختبر مستواها في اللغه العربيه على
مستوى العالم همم وغيرها من اسئله رحناها
على ضيفنا همم اترككم مع الحوار حياك الله
ابو فراس شرفتنا نورت اهلا وسهلا ومرحبتين
مره متحمس اهلا وسهلا فيك والنيابه يعني
همم اسمح لي اني همم اتطفل واقول لكل من
اجتمعنا الصين تراني انا ضغطت على ابو
فراس كلها هذه الحلقه نبغاها نموذج لكيف
تكون اللغه بسيطه وقريبه من المجتمع كما
هو هدف ال ال الجهود الكبيره اللي تصير في
اي شيء يحدث ترى انا مسؤول شو رايك جيد
جيد حتى هذا يخفض على ما يمكن ههه الله
يعطيك العافيه ابو فراس
وايش اللي اختلف في السعوديه ما بين مرحله
تاليف كتاب فتنه القول بتعليم المراه الى
اليوم
شيء شيء يمكن اقول يعني انا انا ان ما
الفت الكتاب فتنه القول بتعليم البنات في
المرحله التي اوشكت الامور ان تتجه الحمد
لله الى
اللحظه العظيمه اللي احنا فيها عام كم
لكن يمكن بحدود يعني تقريبا لكن
المرحله اللي انا اتكلم عنها في الكتاب هي
هي العجيبه والتي اظن اننا بحاجه الى اننا
لن انساها ابدا وانما نتاملها لان اللحظه
الحضاريه الضخمها اللي همم
القياده شالت معها المجتمع من من مستوى
ينظر الى تعليم البنات
من منظور شرعي ان في بعض في بعض المستويات
طبعا انه حرام ويقود الى الفجور وما الى
ذلك الى ان نصبح نشاهد يعني القيادات
العليا هذه ما تتم احيانا 2030 سنه تحتاج
الى مده طويله انا
احديت الكتاب هذا
اذكر انه الى كثيرات لم تفلح مدارس المحو
في ان تقترح شجره الذنب الكبيره التي غرست
حتى وان جاءت مدارس المحور
يعني الاميه وما شابه لكن جيل كامل باسباب
ثقافيه منع من من التعليم لاسباب معينه
همم وكانت دوله متقدمه كثيرا على على
الاستجابه الشعبيه في فتره معينه الى ان
توام الجميع انا همم
اللي ابتدات من همم
الغفور له والراحل الملك عبد العزيز رحمه
الله انه الخيار الخيار العلمي شرط رئيس
في اي نهضه يعني في مستويات عديده المهم
ان انا الان
يستحيل ان ان يفهم الانسان
اذا نظر الى اللحظه المعاصره ما مر بها
المجتمع لان النقله ضخمه جدا اييه هذه
فرصه الكتاب يعني من فتره يعني صدر فرصه
ثانيه ادعو من من تيسر له ان يجد منه نسخه
في باي صيغه ان يطلع على بعض الصفحات
ليعرف ما الذي بدلته الدوله لكي ااه تقطع
مراحل عظيمه جدا في همم في الحركه
الثقافيه والحضاريه يمكن الجميل في في في
همم في سياقها القصه هو انه قاعد يتكرر في
احداث مختلفه مثلا اتذكر همم من القصائد
اللي كانت يعني
في اذني واسمائها بحماس لانه ملقيها
ومؤلفها شاعر مميز على يعني في القراءه
وفي طريقه كتابته اللي هو الشاعر ياسر
التويجري عنده قصيده عن خيانه المراه طبعا
هو همم لاحق انت تبرا منها وتبرع من تلك
المرحله وهي
حقبه معينه من عمره لكنه لا يعني لا يتفق
معها اليوم كان كان من الابيات اللي يقول
فيها همم والله لو تسوق همم البنت همم
في بلدنا ان ان تصير ثوره الشباني او شيء
زي كذا همم بمعنى كان همم يعني
الراي المجتمعي او الاعتقاد المجتمع بانه
قيادات المراه للسياره بتسوي ثوره للشبان
او اتذكر كان يقول همم
للراعي المعارض همم كان بالجنه لا يبيع
للرجال وبلغ الحمراني يعني همم
مثلا دخول الجنه بيع السياره للمراه
فالشاهد منها انه اللي حدث لها حقا همم
قرار سياسي
واكتشفنا انه مجتمع ما كان في ثوره شباني
كان كل شاب واقف جنب اخته وجنب زوجته وجنب
امه يساعدها في السواقه في الصباحات يوم
الجمعه قبل ما تزدحم الشوارع ايمانا بانها
قادر عنها تسوق وانه المجتمع انضج وارقى
من الصوره الذهنيه اللي احنا نحطها احنا
على المجتمع مثل ما حدث في قياده في
التعليم البنات انه كان في النهايه قرار
سياسي واكتشفنا المجتمع اكثر من يرحب به
ويدعمه ويشجع حدوته ربما هذه فرصه نشير
ايضا الى ان الموقف تجاه تعليم البنات
ليس سعوديه وانما انا ارسلت اكثر من من 20
دوله
عربيه واسلاميه وعالميه وغير مسلمه ايضا
عندهم هذا الموقف تكرر بشكل او باخر ايضا
هناك موقف اعنف منه في بعض المستويات تجاه
تعليم الابناء التعليم النظامي لان كان
هناك مفهوم في المجتمع في فتره معينه همم
وقت الملك عبد العزيز الملك سعود الله
يرحمهم انه التعليم سبيل الى الانتقال
والالتزام بالعمل بالعسكريه وبالتالي صار
في مواقف كثيره انه لا تتعلم نظاميه انه
الولد المزرعه او كده بل انه كان في موقف
ثقافي لم يدرس فيما اظن تجاه افتتاح
البلديات افتتاح بلديات هذه مفهوم لطيف
وكذا لكن كان هناك اسباب همم كثيره بالفعل
المجتمع السعودي ماذا اقول انه بحاجه الى
دراسات اجتماعيه عديده في زوايا ثقافيه
زوايا لغويه زوايا همم رياضيه زوايا همم
الزوايا اا طريقه التفكير مفهوم بسيط مثل
مفهوم جيد القيلوله همم تصفير همم صفر
فعلا ولا ما صفر من المفردات اللي عندك
ولا ده يعني من المفردات اللي في في بيئته
يعني اشياء متى انتقل للناس همم وقت النوم
امتدادهم امتداد ساعات همم
العمل دخول يوم الخميس كتب ضد موقف في يوم
الخميس فالدراسات الاجتماعيه هذه مرتبطه
باللويه لكنها همم
غير مختصه لكن
اظن ان همم طرفنا والنكت والكلمات
والسواليف والقصص وتحولات همم الدراسه
والمفردات كلها قابله للدرس والتامل
فيها همم من هو اكبر مني واعلم وركزته على
بعض هذه الاشياء احنا ساعده وفراس همم
امين العام المكلف لمجمع الملك سلمان
العالم اللغه العربيه الله يسعدك همم ومثل
ما شفنا المجتمع يفاجئنا في همم استجابته
السريعه للمتغيرات كثيره كان يعتقد الناس
انه بينه وبينهم فجوه طويله قد نتفاجا
بانه المجتمع اجهز ما يكون للعوده اللغه
العربيه واستخدامها في حياه اليوميه متى
ما وجدت التطبيقات الميسره وجدها قريبه
منه
فالحلقه هذه بدنا نتعرف على المجمع وعلى
اهم تحقق في الفتره الماضيه هو شيخنا تعرف
شو هذا الله يحييك مره ثانيه ويحيي
المشاهدين والمشاهدات والمتابعين
مجمع الملك سلمان العالمي اللغه العربيه
اييه مؤسسه يعني اكيد سعوديه وتتشرف باسم
طويل العمر الله يحفظه وتنشط في النطاق
العالمي معنيه باللوحه العربيه هذه ليست
كلمه هذه اركان رئيسه لعمل المجمع
المجمع حديث النشاح لكن الجهود السعوديه
في خدمه اللغه العربيه همم تاريخيه
واستراتيجيه وعالميه يكفي ان الملك المؤسس
رحمه الله حسنا كثيرا من الجدل والحوارات
والنقاشات الداخليه والعالميه حوله هويه
الدوله فجعل التعريف الاول انها العربيه
فهي المملكه العربيه السعوديه
كليات ومعاهد ومراكز وكراسي وجهود داخليه
وخارجيه
وعشرات توميات القرارات المعنيه بدعم
وتمكين اللغه العربيه
المجمع جاء في سياق مبادرات رؤيه 20 30
اييه ضمن مبادرات وزاره الثقافه في يعني
مسار تنميه القدرات
المنظومه الثقافيه التي يعني تتشرف بقياده
سمو الامير بدر الله يحفظك معنيه للثقافه
ومعنيه بالهويه وما يرتبط بها احد ركائز
الهويه الوطنيه اللغه العربيه طبيعه الحال
همم المجمع جاء على مستوى التاسيس متاخرا
عن همم اشقائه همم في همم الدول العربيه
بعضهم يزيد على ال 50 وال 60 وال 80 سنه
تاسيسا همم لكن الجهود السعوديه قديمه جدا
همم تضارع هذه المده هو همم توازيها
واحيانا تزيد عليها في عدد من الدول لكن
هذا التاخر همم الشكلي في تاسيس المجمع
همم جاء معه متطلبات اخرى فالمجامع
العربيه الشقيقه يكون بجهد كثر الله خير
وهم ما قصروا جهود يعني نبيل وجيد لكنها
مجامع خاصه بالدول ولذلك تحمل همم اسماء
الدول وتركز على همم جغرافيا هذه الدول
بينما المجمع الملك سلمان همم عالمي
واتشرف باسم همم
وارتبط وزاره الثقافه على حين اغلب همم
اغلب ال همم المجامع ترتبط بوزاره التعليم
او وزاره التربيه وهذا له اشاره معينه همم
وهو ان يربط اللغه بالثقافه والا يفهم ان
اللغه هي مستوى همم او نطاق لللغويين فقط
هم هم المسؤول عنها وهم اللي يفصلون في
قضاياها وكانها شيء مستقل عن المجتمع كان
مجرد اداء التواصل وليست جزء
اخر وانها للتواصل فقط همم يعني تقضي حاجه
معينه وتنتهي واللغه في في منظور المجمع
همم ومنظور همم
دولتنا الله يحفظها همم خاصه مع تاسيس
وزاره الثقافه ان اللغه همم جزء من الهويه
فنحن نتكلم همم في المجمع نقول اننا همم
نتخصص في اللغه العربيه اللي هي الجزء
الصلب في هويه الدوله نحن نتكلم عن الماده
الاولى من النظام الاساسي الحكم العربيه
نتكلم عن التشريعات كثيره نص على اللغه
العربيه المجمع جاء همم
لينشط في مجالات لم تنشط فيها المؤسسات
اللغويه همم او اغلب المؤسسات اللغويه لا
تعنى بالنطا لنعنا فيه ونحاول انه نركز
بحماسه كبيره
بنقاط ملخص
عافيه بس ابغى شيء المجمع طبعا احنا
نستشعر التحديات ربما يجي ااا حديث عنها
يعني همم ونؤمن بالفرص
نتكامل مع مع المؤسسات المتنوعه همم نتقوى
بالشركاء من افراد المؤسسات همم تنظيم
المجموع يعني نصف على همم حزمه همم طويله
وعريضه من المهام والاختصار وتنظيم الصادر
من مجلس الوزراء الموكر همم لكن يمكن ان
اجمل همم مسارات العمل في المجمع همم مسار
التخطيط والسياسه اللغويه والمسار البرامج
التعليميه ومسار الحوسبه اللغويه ومسار
البرامج الثقافيه هذه المسارات الرئيسه
همم التي يعمل فيها المجمع ان يقدم همم
هذه همم المسارات مع اطار نعم اننا مؤسسه
ننتمي الى هذه الارض الطيبه ننتمي الى الى
انا وياك جا المكان اا لا نبعد الا
كلمترات بسيطه جدا عن موقع الاعشاب الاعشى
اللي قبل الاسلام همم وهو همم يغني ويسمى
صناجه العرب ننتمي الى هذه الارض اللي همم
يعني جهه الطريق الى همم القسيم والمدينه
تمر على اراضي مر فيها هذه الرمه ومره
فيها الحطيئه وانتماء جرير وهمم شعراء
المتقدمين تصل الى الى اراضي همم القيس
همم وادي الرمه ومالك بن الريب تنتقل يعني
مليئه يعني كل تاريخ اللغه العربيه في هذا
المكان
يعني همم اشهر من اشهر الشخصيات العربيه
في جمع اللغه الاصمعي مثلا وهو يقول
واخذتها من نجد ومن عربيه في نجد وهمم
ويسميها النبال قديما تسمى همم زرته همم
اني باج همم الازهري الازهري كتابه العظيم
تهريب اللغه بعد ان همم احتجز في في منطقه
همم الاحساء واخذ يقول من هؤلاء همم العرب
فاحنا ننتمي الى الى هذه المنطقه العظيمه
والتاريخ الكبير همم اي تاريخ لنا همم
نتكلم عن 100 سنه يتكلم غيرك عن 300 نتكلم
عن 600 نتكلم عن الف نتكلم عن 1500 سنه
هذه العرب ولذلك من المناطق النوعيه اللي
همم احنا نحاول ان نؤكد عليها دائما ان
نقول ان همم اين تذكر كلمه عربي ولا عرب
ولا باي اشتقاق لها او اي استخدام في اي
دوله او اي لغه عالميه عن العرب فانه
يشيرون الى هذه المنطقه تحديدا فالخيار
الوحيد
امامنا في في في بلادنا هو ما همم يعني
همم ياتي في الرؤيه وياتي في كلمات همم
ذلك الله همم ان همم اللغه العربيه
تشريف لانسان هذا المكان وتكليف في الوقت
نفسه المجمع يحاول ان ينهض بهذه المهمه في
واحد ارسلنا يقول ما حسلهم داعي لو انهم
تحت هيئه الادب والنشر وكان ادت الغرض بدل
تكرارها الاجهزه وش الفرق بينكم وبين ال
ال الاجهزه الاخرى في وزاره الثقافه اللي
معنيه بموضوع اللغه العربيه
ايهم اوسع الادب او اللغه او الثقافه همم
او حتى لو توسعت شوي وقلنا الموسيقى او لو
توسعنا اكثر وقلنا همم رمزيات الثقافيه
العامه سواء الملابس او ما شابه
طبعا جميعا نؤدي ادوار نوعيه نص عليها
المشرع وكلنا لا نتنظيمات من مجلس الوزراء
الموقر وربما يعني مثلا
اللغه جزء من الادب لكن هناك من يكون
اللغه هي عن الان هي اللي تخرج منها
الفنون والمسرات المتنوعه لكن احنا نقول
النطاق بنعمل فيه ويعمل فيها المجمع يختلف
عن الطاقه التي تعمل فيها بقيه الحياه
وزملائكم بجهود نوع جدا سواء في هذه الادب
او غير ان انا اظن ان شاء الله همم سوف
تشترك معنا هيئات همم ان شاء الله همم
موسيقى ومعانيها ومعنيه بالطهي اضافه الى
شبكات قبل مع العماره همم
لان جزء من ما ذكرته قبل قليل وهو انتماء
المجمع الى حاضن الوزاره ان ال- همم اللغه
نريد
لا نريد ان يفهم ان اللغه هي اا زاويه
معينه نفتح الكتاب ندخل المكتبه ولا نسال
استاذه نحو او الصرف او البلاغه نحن نريد
ان نقول ان اللغه هي الثقافه بمعنى انك
تسمع همم
المنشاوي بطبقات عجيبه جدا او تسمع همم
مؤدي جساس من المنطقه الغربيه بطبقات
عجيبه او مغني علينا ان ان ان ان ننتبه
الى لحظه مهمه ان من يطلب لاغنيه قد يطلب
لموسيقى لكن يفهم دلاله الكلمه سوف يطرب
الى ما هو اعمق همم في ربط الموسيقى
بهذه الكلمه هو همم غيرها همم همم التسميه
همم يعني بس لتوضيح يعني يسير المجمع همم
ينتمي الى المنظومه الثقافيه وهو واحد من
مبادرات المنظومه الثقافيه والاطلقها اسمه
بدر لكنه ليس من اجهزه وزاره الثقافه على
حين ان الهيئات ترتبط همم الوزارات مختلفه
عن ارتباط المجمع المجمع مستقبل ماريا
واداريا واغلب المهام لا يشتري فيها مع
الجهات اضافه الى ان المجمع بحسب اسمه همم
عالمي وليس همم يعني همم فقط في النطاق
الوطني همم وقد سند له همم تنظيمه من مجلس
الوزراء توحيد المرجعيه فيما يخص اللغه
العربيه وطنيا والعمل على ذلك دوليا
[موسيقى]
في عصر رقمي متغير باستمرار المواكبه هي
اساس النجاح ولاننا رواد المستقبل الرقمي
نوظف خبراتنا وقدراتنا لنمكن نبتكر نبدع
في تبني احدث التقنيات وتوفير الحلول
بكفاءه وذكاء سلوشن سبايسي
[موسيقى]
2019 ضيعنا 50 سنه في الحديث عن تحديات
اللغه العربيه
في البدايه يعني
انا فريق يعني تشرفت بثقه همم
لكن نحن فريق بوزاره الثقافه بالرؤيه من
همم سمو الامير
في الوزاره والمبادره يعني انطلقت من
الوزاره
[موسيقى]
ثم اذهب الى المدرسه
استشعار التحديات مهم ومفيد
لكن نستطيع ان نجلس جلسات طويله ونحن
نتكلم عن التحديات ثم نخرج وقد تكلمنا عن
التحديات لكن ماذا عن الحديث افضل هو الذي
يتيح لك يعني العمل وان تنجز وان تبدل من
ان تجد تفكر ثروه انك تبيعوا تشريع يعني
حتى تصل يعني بدل ما نتكلم عن ازمه اللغه
العربيه وبدنا نتكلم عنها غيرنا ويجب ان
نتكلم عنها بصيغه معينه لكن الافضل ان
نتحدث عن الفرص والممكنه غير ذلك همم انا
افترض ان بقيه الحوار بيدخل فيه تفاصيل
اخرى ولذلك همم اتحدث عن الفرس او ان همم
المبادرات بدءا من اخر عمل همم انجزناه
قبل همم يعني الحضور همم اليك الله يسلمك
همم كنا في الايام ال- ال- القليله
الماضيه نشترك همم على غير المعتاد من
المؤسسات اللغويه
متعه ومع الشرك انا اشترك في القمه
العالميه للذكاء همم الصناعي بمفهوم نوع
جدا الذكاء الصناعي خير لسعد البشريه
ويدخل مجمع الملك سلمان شركه المعرفيه هذه
التبخره على حين كان همم المنتظر او الافق
التوقع كما يقال في النقد عند همم من
يتعامل مع اللغه بصيغه تقليديه يتوقعون
انه همم ننفذ مؤتمر عن صعوبات تعلم همم
الاملاء همم ان ننفذ مؤتمر همم حول همم
جهود خليل بن احمد رحمه الله وهذه علوم
ومسرات مهمه جدا بصيغه معينه لكن نحن
ذهبنا همم اول الشركات الى سجائر وابدانا
معهم بشركه نوويه ثم همم انتقلنا الى الى
شركات تقنيه ثم ذهبنا الى همم الجامعات
همم مؤخرا فنحن همم يعنيون بان همم نعمل
في المنطقه التي لم يعمل فيها غيرنا وان
نحاول
نصير ما هو بيقول لهم مثل باقي على الثلج
بائع الثلج عنده طريقه للتسويق طريفه
طبعا هذه تراثيه لكنها لطيفه يقول لك بائع
الثلج حتى يسوق
كيف يسوق الثلج جهه اول وكان يحمل الثلج
ويقول ارحموا من راس ماله يذوب
انت لو شفت واحده يسوق بهذا الشكل لو انك
ما تبي الثالث
احنا لا نؤمن بان اللغه العربيه في في طور
ذوبان له لكن الوسائل التي تخدم ان لم
تلحق بها سريعا
فستفودك يعني مبكرا ولذلك اهم ما همم يعني
ما ما استطيع ان اوجه اننا همم نعمل في
قطاع الحوسبه على الاتي
اولا اصدار المعجم المعاصر للغه العربيه
وذلك يحقق توفير الخدمه اللغويه والمرادف
والبديل والترجمه بشكل سريع جدا وهذه
المبادره التي بدانا عليها طبعا المجمع
يمر في مرحله تاسيس وان شاء الله يشكل
قريبا مجلس هنا خارج بطبيعه الحال يعني
صلاحيته عند عند
العليا
المستهدفات له في 25 لكن احنا همم 2025
اكتمال له كامله لكن احنا نجتهد انه في 23
سوف تنطلق همم 23 تقريبا كان طريق المرحله
الاولى من همم تصل الى همم
جذر همم كلمه طبعا والجذر لمن يعني الجميع
يعني انها تقول لك مجموعه من المصطلحات
لكن همم 23 تطبيق موجود اقدر احم او موجه
موجود باذن الله لكن التحدي ان نستطيع قبل
ذلك هل نستطيع ان نتجاوز الثمانين همم
اكتمال المشروع كامل لفظ 25 لكن التحديات
الاكبر نصل الى همم ما هو اقل على مستوى
المده واكثر على مستوى همم المواد هذه
المعجم الثاني افتتاح مركز همم الذكاء
الاصطناعي لمعالجه همم العربيه وهذا يلزم
ان يكون همم متاحا في 23 همم القريبه طبعا
لا يوجد همم اي مؤسسه لغويه تعنى او تؤسس
مركز في الذكاء الاصطناعي لمعالجه الدول
العربيه المجمع الان يعمل همم سوف يكون
مركز جاهز لمعرفه
معالجته اللغه الطبيعيه اللغه العربيه هل
هو هذا السيريال هذه الاجهزه طبعا احنا
عندنا تحديات لازم همم
كميه التحديات ان احنا نتكلم عن اللغه
التقنيه جايه من لغه اخرى يعني ابسطها
تتعامل التقنيه الخاصه بي اللغه
الانجليزيه والتقنيات الموجوده كذا كذا ان
احرف مقطعه اللغه العربيه
تتعامل من اليسار الى اليمين ان احنا
نتكلم من اليمين الى اليسار تتعامل مع
لغات ينظر فيها اثر التشكيل اللغه العربيه
تعنى بالتشكيل تتعامل مع مستويات كتابه
تقريبا مستقره بين اللغه العربيه همم تعنى
بمستويات معينه مثل الرحمن موجود الالف من
عدمها همم نصف القران له كتابه النص
الشعري له كتابه النص كما تتعامل مستوى
تقريبا واحد من اللغه همم احنا عند
المستويات عديده ونشهر ان هذه مصادر القوه
يجب ان تكون مصادر القوه في مركز الذكاء
يفتتح في 23 وهمم يفترض انه يعمل على
مجموعه من المبادرات همم من الاعمال التي
انطلقت المرحله الاولى منها اكتملت
المرحله الاولى
انه سوف يستمر وهو برمجان العربيه جمع
اللغويين والتقاليين ظلت اللغه العربيه
مده طويله جدا وتقريب ما زالت الى الان
نحن نحاول نجتهد مع شركائنا ان نخرج اللغه
العربيه من هذا المستوى وظلت مسؤوليه
اللغويه
اي قضيه ترتبط باللوح يسال استاذ النحو
والصرف والبناغه والنقد وهذا شيء قيم جدير
لهم حق من حقهم وهذا تخصصهم يجب ان نفهم
انه علم ومن حق ما يكون رايه ولكن اللغه
العربيه ليست في اللغويه فقط للجميع هي
بنت الثقافه ومرتبطه بالثقافه من حق همم
كبيره السن ان ان يكون له راي في تداول
اللغه ومعناها من حق عالم الاجتماع همم ان
ان يعطي حكما حول صلاحيه كلمه وارتباطها
هي المجتمع والدلالاتها من حق همم
الاعلامي ان يفهم من هذه اللغه اعلاميه
جيده او هذه لا تستخدم ان هذه مفهومه او
غير مفهومه من حق همم الرياضي همم عندما
همم تنتشر كلمه همم
همم في الملاعب ان ان يطالب
باحتضانها عربيا همم ولذلك نحن نقول اننا
نعمل على جمع همم في برمجه العربيه انتهت
ضد المرحله الاولى ووصلنا الى بعضها
المخرجاتها من ابسطها او من الطفها هل
تستطيع ان
ان تعطي الجهاز ان تعطي الجهاز مجموعه
ضخمه جدا من المدونات والكلمات والافكار
وكذا وكذا تطلب منهم يكتب قصيده كمثال
تبع لذلك هل تستطيع ان تعطي الجهاز مجموعه
كبيره من الكلمات ضخمه جدا هذا واحد من
المسؤلات الحوسبه اللغويه نبني المدونات
المئويه الضخمه وكل ما اصبحت عندك مدونات
ضخمه جدا تستطيع ان تخرج منها ااا ادوات
ضخمه جدا ونوعيه الان ما الكلمات التي
تنتشر عند طلاب الثانويه في مرحله
الاختبارات مما يعنى بها
العالم الاجتماعي او همم العالم التربيه
في وزاره التعليم او حتى الجهات الامنيه
كيف تستطيع ان تصدها كيف تستطيع ان تفهم
شفرات فيها اذا وجدت مدونه ضخمه استطعت
عبر تقنيات الذكاء ان تخرج الكلمات
الشائعه عند الرياضيين عند الاعلاميين عند
الاطفال تستطيع ان تحكم على لغه الاطفال
وهم ينمون ما هي الكلمات المناسبه لهم همم
الذين يتعلمون اللغه العربيه من غير العرب
كيف تستطيع ان تقول ان افضل معجم يقدم لهم
هو المعجم الفلاني لو اعطيت استاذ خبيرا
همم لم يدخل في في وسائل التقنيه والذكاء
الاصطناعي سوف يخرج عبر الخبره والتدريس
وما شابه لكن همم ليس الوقت وقت كافي
للخبره فقط وانما نحتاج همم
الاصطناعي ليساند في هذه الجوانب هذا
برمجنا العربيه همم يتكامل مع مركز الذكاء
ويتكامل مع همم المعجم المعاصر في في نطاق
همم
الحوسبه اضافه الى المدونات العديده التي
نبنيها بنايه يعني همم بناء متواصلا في
مسارات همم متنوعه همم من المجالات التي
نعمل عليها في قطاع التخطيط اللغوي
التخطيط والسياسه اللغويه
ونروح للتخطيط في همم سواء بسيط همم تقرير
الحاله الثقافيه لوزاره الثقافي يقول لم
تشهد الذكاء الاصطناعي والتقنيه والتقنيه
تطورات كبرى همم
كيف نجمع ما بين كلامهم او او او او رصدهم
وبين جهود اللي انتم قاعدين قاعدين
تسوونها خصوصا نحن مثلا همم قاعدين نشوف
انه هذه اغلبها ما بعد وصلت للناس كلها
لسه في المطبخ ايش رايك طبعا
المجمع انطلاق اعمال المجمع الفعليه هو في
شهر خمسه الهجري الماضي 12 الميلادي ما
قبله كان يعني تاسيس وما شابه لكن فعلي
انطلقنا في همم ديسمبر الماضي همم عبر
تويتر وبدات الاعمال همم بالعكس هذا
الكلام الذي تشير اليه همم هذا الذي يفترض
ان جعله في المجمع همم يعني خط اساس ان
نعمل عليه يفترض ان هذا التقرير المحايد
همم ويصدر من المرجعيه تقريبا متشابهه
يفترض ان اعمال المجمع لاحقا تنعكس على
هذا التقرير التحدي لو لم تمتنعكس لو لم
يستطع المجمع باعماله ال- ال- في هذه
السنه ان ان يحدث همم تغيرا في هذا همم
ولذلك همم نعتقد انه يتكلم بس انا الماضيه
كما تعلم يصدر تقرير همم سنه سابقا او
مرحله سابقه همم واظن مشار الى بدايه
اعمال المجمع لكن نحن عازمون باذن الله
عبر زملائي وزميلاتي في قطاع الحوسبه ان
ينعكس هذا الاثر ليس فقط على على هذا
التقرير وانما على الممارسه الفعليه همم
ولذلك انا اضيف الى اننا همم حتى في همم
جائزه المجمع العالميه لم نجعلها
لانطاقات المعتاده وانما حتى من خدموا
اللغه في مجال الحوسبه من الافراد او
المؤسسات سوف يقدر المجمع جهودهم ننتقل
امام
الموضوعيه همم اللغه هي علم
ونحن نقود يجب ان لا تنحصر عند اللغويين
فقط
والاساتذه الكرام الذين يقومون بجهد وما
زالوا يقومونه مميزون يقوم بجهد نوعي في
النحو والصرف وغيره وان هي علم يفترض ان
يستجيب لمنطق العلم
تخصص التخطيط اللغوي قليل في جميع اللغات
في اللغه العربيه قليل جدا نعتقد ان
المملكه العربيه السعوديه في سنوات
بدات جهود عديده من الخبراء
والزملاء من الخبيرات في هذا المجال
يتخصصون بنشاط قوي المجمع جهالي يشكل
القطاعا كاملا ويرتبط به ايضا مركز همم
متخصص في التخطيط والسياسه اللغويه ثم
مفهوم التخطيط السياسه اللغويه اولا هو
الا نتكلم عن اللغه الاجتهادات والتوقعات
والتجارب الشخصيه عندهم تجربه شيء كويس
انا همم رحت لهند ترى رام الله جديدين
عندهم شيء الفلاني ترى تجبتنا في المدارس
الفلانيه انجلوها عندكم
جيد ترى همم المجمع وكذا كتاب فلان هذا
يفترض ان يكون جزء من همم المعلومات لكن
المعلومه يجب ان تاتي من خبراء في التغطيه
السياسيه في مساره التخطيط والسياسه
اللغويه احنا نعمل حزمه متنوعه جدا من
الاعمال من اهمها من اهمها
اا العنايه
بمنزله اللغه العربيه في المنظمات الدوليه
هذا نطاق لا يعمل فيه احد حاليا غير
المجمع مع جهود بسيطه لبعض المؤسسات
المملكه العربيه السعوديه هي اهم داعم
للغه العربيه
ليتم او لتعتمد في الامم المتحده وداعا
باللغه العربيه في عده منظمات لكن لا يوجد
دعم فعلي يعني الدعم السياسي موجود لكن
اين اللغوي اين المشروع اللغوي اين تدريب
المترجمين في المنظمات المتعدده همم
الجهود في عموم المنظمات همم قليله جدا
همم قليله من الجهود السعوديه
في برنامج امير سلطان الله يرحمه يعني همم
راقي ومميز همم المجمع في هذه المده ال-
ال- يتكلم همم من ديسمبر همم الماضي نحن
الان همم انجزنا البرنامج الاول مع الامم
المتحده
لا اكثر من بعين ممثلا من 40 دوله في همم
نيويورك وحظي حضور ورئاسه رئيس الجمعيه
العامه وطبعا عقد البرنامج برعايه سمو
الامير بدر وحضور نوعي لاغلب الممثل اغلب
السفراء العرب وشعر بان هناك من يسال عن
اللغه العربيه هذا المستوى بيحدداته همم
مهمه لكن لا نتفق عنده نحن نعمل على مسرات
متنوعه لا نعمل في الامم المتحده على
البرنامج القادم في ديسمبر القادم ان شاء
الله برنامج سوف يكون همم اوسع واكثر تنوع
يشمل همم دورات تدريبيه للمترجمين ويشمل
الاصدار همم كتب عن تاريخ اللغه العربيه
في الامم المتحده وترجمه مجموعه من الكتب
من والى همم اللغه العربيه في الامم
المتحده في الوقت نفسه همم لدينا مفهمه
قائمه حاليا مع همم المنظمه همم الاسلاميه
الاكبر المنظمه التعاون الاسلامي لاطلاق
برنامج حول اللغه العربيه لغه الشعوب
الاسلاميه
والعمليه تصاعد بشكل بدات برامجنا في همم
دورات التدريبيه والتعاون مع ال ايسكو
بعمل متصاعد ونفذت برامج همم تدريبيه
وبرامج همم ندوات ومحاضرات بالتعاون معهم
الذين توصلون وشوشكم وش الهدف في المنظمه
همم نسعى الى دعم العاملين في حقل الترجمه
من والى اللغه العربيه في هذه المنظمات
تمكين استمرار اللغه العربيه من اللغات
العالميه الست هذا همم من من لم يتنبه
لمعنى ان تكون اللغه العربيه من اللغات ست
عليها ان يتذكر ان لغه مثل اللغه
الالمانيه ليست من الوقت فوجود اللغه
العربيه همم ضمن اللغات العالميه السته
المعتمده هذا قفز نوعيه السعوديه ولله
الحمد من همم قاعده الدول التي دعمت هذا
الخيار ان شاء الله قريب من همم المجمع
لكن هذا الوصول لا يعني الاستمرار
يجب ان يدعم هذا الخيار بممكنات بترجمه
بمعاجم بكتب بالتدريب المترجمين بدعم
الخيار اللغوي وهذا ما يعمل عليه المجمع
في عده منظمات الذين عمل اا قريه قادم ان
شاء الله مع الفيفا ونتوقع النصر الى
منظمات اخرى في المده القريبه القادمه
دعما لهذا الخيار تشرفنا بموافقه خادم
الحرمين الشريفين الله يحفظه على رعايه
همم المؤتمر الدولي الاول الذي ينظم
المجمع بعنوان اللغه العربيه في المنظمات
الدوليه وسوف يشارك فيه همم رؤساء منظمات
ومعانيون وخبراء همم نعتقد انه لم يسبقا
جاءهم من يقول ان هناك سؤال حول اللغه
العربيه في هذه المنظمات وتعلم ان العمل
في المنظمات الدوليه عمل الاستراتيجي وهم
لاي دوله همم المملكه العربيه السعوديه
الجديده ان تكون هذا همم
دعم اللغه العربيه في نظام الدوليه من
خلال ترجمه الكتب وتقديم دورات تدريبيه
لموظفين منظمات والمساهمه في انفاذ تملك
العربيه نعم بلغه الارقام كم دربته كم
كتاب ترجمته الان اا سوف ينطلق البرنامج
التدريبي المفاهم الاولى تمت في الموسم
الماضي مع همم الامم المتحده وينطلق
البرنامج تدريب معلومه متحده ان شاء الله
فيها القديمه القادمه نتوقع ان ان لا يكون
متوقف الذي نعمل عليه انه حين يبدا
التدريبي مع الامم المتحده يفترض ان يستمر
همم ويكون متصاعدا الترجمه الكتب الان
نعمل على الترجمه وسوف تطلق ان شاء الله
25 عدد اشخاص الان حزمه التدريب التي
انطلقت بدا من ديسمبر الماضي هي علامه
حزمه التدريب التي تقع ليس ضمن التخطيط
وان من ضمن التخطيط وبقيت قطاعات المجموعه
هو تدريب وطني وسعودي وتدريب يعني خارجي
خارجي همم تجاوز 29 همم دوره تدريبيه همم
همم وصلوا حتى الان في هذه الاشهر اقل من
من سنه ربما تسع اشهر همم اكثر من من 700
يعني مختص همم التدريب ادى الوطني همم
حاليا دربنا اكثر من 1700 موظف على موظف
سعودي طبعا هذا في نطاق التدريب العام
وليس في نطاق اللغه
والمنظمات مسار اللغه والمنظمات هو مسار
الاساسي همم السياسي خارج نطاق عمل
المجموع ولذلك دخول اللغه العربيه والدخول
همم
ونظريا يعني بدانا بالمفاهمات التجاره همم
عبر زملاء الكرام في وزاره الثقافه وزاره
التجاره السعوديه سؤال اللغه العربيه اول
ما همم يعني بدات المفاهمه مع منظمه
التجاره سؤال انا نحن مختصين اللغه كيف
همم تنفذ برامج في المنظمات التجاره وان
احنا نعتقد انه من حق اللغه العربيه وهي
من الواتس ان تحدث في جميع المنظمات بل ان
الرهان الكبير الذي يسعى اليه كيف نستطيع
ان نمكن اللغه العربيه في جميع
حاضر منظم التجارب يعني انك تصير في
الموقع الرسمي قال اللغه موجوده في
وسائقهم وفي ان ان يجد العربي همم حاجته
بلغته في اي مكان هذا مو موجود اليوم هدف
عظيم ومرتفع لكن يجب ان سائله ليس موجود
في جميع المنظمات ليس موجوده في جميع
المواد
يخلون الموقع موجود نريد
كل المستندات هذه المنظمه يتاح نسخه
باللغه العربيه
لكن اكيد انا لا نستطيع ان ننفذه مستقلين
همم لابد ان نتبوه بشركاء الوطنيين
سعوديين
والتوام مع هذه المنظمه وغيرها هناك سؤال
حول منظمه الفيفا نحن نعتقد انها جميع
انواع الرياضيات وفي الرياضيات يفترض ان
ان توفر للعربي بلغته هذا لا يعني همم عدم
همم وجود اللغات الاخرى ابدا لكن هو خيار
عربي يجب الناس عائليه جميعا همم حتى وان
كان همم ذهب العربي
خادفات مريحين انتم بدون استادات
نحن الان نستهدف في انا اردت يكمل ثريا عن
التخطيط ثم اذهب الى التعليم ثم اذهب الى
البرامج الثقافيه لكنك الان في موضوع
منظماتكم
الوصول الى جميع المنظمات لتكون اللغه
العربيه لتكون خيارا همم اساسيا فيها ما
دام المنظمه الام وهي الامم المتحده
اعتمدوا اللغه العربيه من ضمنها همم
المستهدفه الاول الوصول الى جميع المنظمات
متى وهذا همم
مرتبط حزمه كبيره جدا
لا يعني بهذا الشكل نحن نستهدف ان ننجز
اعمالنا في 25 لكن الوصول الى 57 منظمه
عالميه يعني مثلا يختلف ان تعمل مع
الاتحاد الافريقي كمثال لو فكرنا فيه او
مع الفيفا او تعمل مع همم الايسيسكو وهي
منظمه اسلاميه انا اقول يختلف مستوى
سهل الله يقويكم في اطار زمني في المساء
225 في مسار المنظمات نحن نعتقد اننا همم
نستهدف في هذا الامر في 25 لكن ليس الوصول
الى جميع المنظمات نحن نركز على المنظمات
السته ال- ال- الكبرى التي نعمل معها لكن
ان تترجم ان تكون عن همم المنظمه بترجمه
همم ما لديها او بيترجمه الموقع او ما
شابه هذا حمل همم
المجمع فقط ولذلك نحاول ان نقوي الصله
بالمنظمه ونحاول ان نقوي مثل البرامج
الراديفه الدائمه مثل همم
حضور هذه المنظمات لمؤتمر دولي همم كان
يفترض ان يحضرون الى همم
هذه المنظمات الى مؤتمر عن التعليم او
مؤتمر عن همم نفكر في العالم ومؤتمر
التنميه ومؤتمر عن الاسكان لكن ان تحضر
المؤتمر عن اللغه العربيه هذا سؤال صعب
نعتقد انه سيفتح لنا مجالات خاصه انه
يتشرف هذا الموتور برعايه همم الملك الله
همم تبعا له سوف نوقع مجموعه من الشركات
ونعتك انها فرصه للانطلاق مجموعه همم
الاعمال الثالث في في بقيه همم الله يسلمك
لدينا همم
نعمل على همم مجموعه من السياسات اللغويه
التي يفترض ان تصدر لتنظيم همم استخدام
اللغه العربيه بشكل عام همم لا بد ان نصل
في 23 الى اكثر من من همم 20 سياسه لغويه
ومفهوم السياسه وجود تنظيم او قرار او
نظام او همم معايير او همم يعني بدلا من
ان نقول والله اللغه العربيه جيده وتنص
عليها الانظمه
والتعميم وافترا نقول انه يشير الى تنظيم
معين او نشير الى رقم هذا المسار الثاني
لدى همم تخطيط
هذا وطني اضافه الى ما نحاول ان نساعده
على مستوى دوري
في في اسئله كثيره عليه
نرجع نكمل احنا ما زلنا في المسار الثاني
صح في التخطيط والسياسه اللغويه همم هذا
خالد سليمان كاتب صحفي معروف في مايو 2022
يقول اقترح همم اقترح عليه اقترح على
الدكتور ان يشارك بعض الوزراء والمسؤولين
السعوديين الذين يتحدثون باللغه
السعوديه في البرمجه لعله يساعدهم في تذكر
رغم الام واهميه الاعتزاز بالنطق بها في
مؤتمرات ومنتديات تقام في قلب جزيره العرب
اللغه العربيه هل من ضمن السياسات اللي
انت مشغله عليها او شيء هل انت تعتقد انه
سليم همم ظهور المسؤولين السعوديين في
السعوديه
وحديثهم باللغه الانجليزيه اللي دائما
انهم يقولون حجتهم بانه نحنا قاعدين
نخاطبوا بالعالم وهذا مؤتمر في حضور اجنبي
وفي بث اجنبي وش رايك في هالفعل الموضوع
من المحسوم لدي ان
اللغه الوطنيه واللغه الهويه يجب ان تكون
هي الخيار الاول في اي حضور من اي مستوى
لكن هذا لا يتعاند ولا يتعارض مع اي متغير
مفهوم عند اللغوي وعندها السياسي بطبيعه
الحال وهو اخبر انه عندما يلجا الى خيار
اخر لبدا هذه المجمع لا يتفهمها فقط وانما
يؤمن بها لكن عندما نتكلم عن مواطن يحضر
مؤتمر في المملكه العربيه السعوديه من حقه
ان يستمع الى المؤتمر بلغته حسب الانظمه
التي تنص على ذلك في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه وايضا تبعا لذلك من حقي المريض
ان يتوجه لان يتوجع بلغه همم لغه اخرى لان
يجد همم صعوبه في ايصال المهمه الى الطبيب
والتالي على المؤسسه الطبيه على المؤسسه
همم في الطيران على المؤسسه في التجاره ان
توفر الخدمات للمواطن وهذه سياده همم مهمه
جدا همم يدعمها القانون والتشريه همم واكد
اهميه ان يكون الخيار اللغوي الوحيد هو
اللغه العربيه في اي حضور سعودي الا وفقه
ما همم يراه المسؤول فيه مجانا همم
تنظيم مقترح او نظام مقترح للغه العربيه
همم رفع من المجمع
ويخضع للدراسه في همم يعني همم الجهات
العليا
ونتوقعتين باللغه العربيه نحن نرى ان همم
انه يجب على المتحدث ان يقدم المعلومه
التي يستهدف بها العربي باللغه العربيه
المواطن باللغه العربيه
[موسيقى]
يلا تريتو يا هلا والله انا خالد القحطاني
وانا عبيد الله العيسى بدانا معكم مرتده
في البوت كاسي الرياضي اللي يحلل اهم
احداث الكره السعوديه كسبنا من خلال ثقتكم
وتفاعلكم والمركز الاول في كل حلقه الشيخ
خلانا نطمح بنا نتقدم خطوه
المونديال هو اكبر موسم دراما من يوم
انولدت الكوره قبل 150 سنه بدات في مسيرته
رونالدو
مثل زين الدين زيدان
عشان كده قررنا ناخذ خطوه جديده ونكون
معكم صوت وصوره في مونديال 2022 الحدث
النادر في كل شيء تقريبا هذه اول مره يقام
في بلاد عربيه هذه ايضا اول مره يقام
بتوقيت هنا الشتوي والاهم من ذلك ان هذا
المونديال هو بمثابه الرقصه الاخيره
بلاعبين عظيمين جدا بقيمه كريستيانو
رونالدو وليونيل ميسي راح نحلل معكم افكار
المدربين ونقف فيه على كل جمله
مع منتخب الوطني اللي بيشارك للمره
السادسه واحنا نستمتع كلنا جميعا باجواء
مونديال 2022 في طريقتنا اللي تعودتم
عليها وحبيتها كوب قهوه وسواليف بتحليل
الدقيق وارقام مستدله تابعونا في كاسده
على قنوات 8 كما نصرت البوتاس واليوتيوب
ولسه فيها الاجنبي المفهوم ان يتكلم بلغه
اخرى اذا كان يستهدف الاجنبي لكن
موجود في المملكه العربيه السعوديه
ترجمه فانا اتكلم عن
مسؤول في دوله خارجيه فمن طبيعي يتكلم اذا
كان يتقن اللغه المعديه يتكلم باللغه لتصل
الرساله سريع في مثال هنا
تشبه اللباس متى يختار السعودي ان يلبس
همم ثوبه في في مكان معين لابد ان يعني لم
يختار السعوديه ان يذهب الى اليونسكو او
الى الامم المتحده ويلبس الثوب الا اللي
رساله معينه ما الذي يختلف بين الثوب
هذا مستوى يجب ان ان نربط اللغه بالثقافه
في هنا مدرستين كده تتنازع لمدرسه تقول يا
اخي هذه هويتنا اللي
ما يقدر يعرف عربي نوفلوا مترجم بس انا
مسؤول رسمي سعودي
مؤتمر في السعوديه واتكلم بالانجليزي هذه
فيها انسلاخ وفيها انهزام يعني غير مقبول
هل يوجد نظر ثانيه تقول احنا اليوم العالم
والعالم يتحدث لغه
اختارها لتكون هي اللغه
المشتركه بينهم اللغه الانجليزيه في جزء
من ثقافتنا جزء من تعلمنا جزء من افتتاحنا
على العالم متواصلنا معه اللي ما يعقد
الامور يعني زي مثلا الفرنسيه عرفت اتكلم
انجليزي بس يتعمل يتكلم بالفرنسيه وانت
تدبر نفسك
تقول لا انت يعني لا تعقدها وتواصل معاهم
بالانجليزي طالما انت تعرف انجليزي وهلا
قاعد قدام المانيا يعرف انجليزي خلاص حاكي
بالانجليزي مباشره انت تميل اي انا انا
همم اكيد اني مع مع الخيار الاول لكن ليس
بالوصف الدقيقه اللي كانت تفضلت بذكره همم
انا امير مع خيار انه يجب ان يكون الخيار
العربي اللغه العربيه هي الوحيده همم
واستخدام غيرها هو لظروف لسياك معين وجود
في دوله اجنبيه ولا همم الحضور اجنبيه فقط
اما الحضور سعودي مع مجموعه من الاجانب ف
همم عليهم ان ان يوفروا الترجمه لهم لكن
همم لكن يعني متاكد ان اغلب الذين يتكلمون
همم دون هذا باختلاف اختلاف هذه الرؤيه لا
يعانون من الحزام وانما يعني وفقا العباره
انما يعني غفله او نسي يعني او ربما همم
ظن ان ان الخيار الافضل بهذا الشكل همم
لان التجربه للمجمع التعاون مع جميع
القطاعات السعوديه همم جميع همم اصحاب
المعالي همم جميع المسؤولين حماسه عاليه
جدا العربيه واللغه العربيه خيار لهم يعني
لا يوجد احد يشعر ان اللغه ضعيفه او سيئه
او غير مناسبه همم كلهم يراها يعني خيار
مهم بل لاني يعني نحن نقول ان الفارق في
المملكه العربيه السعوديه عن غيرها من
الدول وبعض الدول العربيه ان اللغه
العربيه مسؤوليه الجميع ويجب ان تكون
مسؤوليه الجميع وليست وظيفه المجمع يعني
يفترض
معلومه اللي موجود عندنا وهذا رائع جدا
ونحن ندعم ونقوي ليكون المجمع همم يعني
مرجعيه او عقل يحرك عضلات اللي موجود وهذا
رائع جدا احنا رصدنا اكثر من 11 معجم لغوي
11 لغوي صدر من جهات سعوديه لم يصدر من
المجمع ولمن كليه اللغه العربيه يعني من
عده مؤسسات وزارات اثرت معالجه شيء رائع
جدا لان اللغه مسؤوليه وليست وليست وظيفه
المجمع ولذلك لدينا اللقاء قريب جدا ان
شاء الله مجموعه من الوزارات والحياه
نناقش معهم الجهود جهودهم في تمكين
العربيه في همم نطاق عملهم يعني ما الذي
تفعله همم من جهد مقدر وزاره الصحه ما
الذي تفعله من جهد المقدر وزاره التجاره
وزاره الحج او كذا من اصدار النعاجم او
كذا لخدمه الحقل التي تنتبه اليه ليس هذه
خدمه اللغه بشكل عام وانما يتداول همم
اللغه موضوع ان ترى مع الخيار هذا خيار ان
تكون اللغه العربيه هي همم
بتفضيل هذا الامر هذه كانت واحده من
الماخذ على المرحله السابقه في الرؤيه انه
مع كثره المؤتمرات والانفتاح العالم يعني
همم انجرفنا في هذا المسار نقطه ثانيه
اغلب الذين يذهبون لا يذهبون ترابي بنيه
انه انه طبعا دخلنا في النوايا يعني
الله يسلمك يظن انه هذا التوجه
لو كان توجهها
لم يكن
الدوله الملك الله يحفظه يقول هذه الكلمات
الثمينه جدا عن اللغه العربيه الامير محمد
في الرؤيه الله يحفظه وهو يشير الى العمق
التاريخي وثقافي الحضاري فنقول وهي اول
ركزيما
لكن فقط انا افسر
وانما هي رؤيا ولا تقدير معين ولا غفله
الماخذ الاول في ماخذ ثاني على الموضوع
برده مرتبط بالمرحله الماضيه يقول عبد
الله سليم في ديسمبر 21 المساله ليس
التهويدا ولكن ما نشاهد الاخيره من مظاهر
اساء العربيه ناشئه عن ذلك التساهل في
حمايتها والسن القوانين وصوتها والحفاظ
عليها ومن هذه المظاهر السيئه اعتمادا
الانجليزيه في التسميات التجاريه همم وفي
الاعلانات والتشويقات الدعائيه همم مثل
همم يعني
بوليفار سيتي سنتر داون تاون هو يرى انه
هذه كلها
اساء اللغه العربيه هل من ضمن السياسات
والانظمه اللي انتم تشتغل عليها شيء مرتبط
بتسميه الاماكن في السعوديه صحيح وانا نص
على ذلك يعني ما قبل السياسات الرؤيه التي
لدينا هي ان مجال المجمع حسب تنظيمه من
مجلس الوزراء ليعمل على سد هذه الفجوه لكن
حتى نكون واقعيين علينا ان ان نفهم اطراف
الموضوع
النقطه التي ذكرتها لك قبل قليل ليست همم
للاستهلاك الاعلاميه حقيقه يعني الوزارات
والهيئات المؤمنه جدا واللغه العربيه خيار
لديهم واغلب ما نشاهده ليس توجهها وانما
لظروف معينه جاءت همم
بدليل وجود جهود الى اليهم هذا اولا ثانيا
همم من يعمل في همم الفاعليات والمؤسسات
والجاتوه بحاجه الى الى لغه نشطه مع ع
وتوفر له مصطلحات وتوفر له ولا بد ان يشير
ونكون واقعيين ان اللغه العربيه وهذه من
التحديات التي اشارته همم اليها قبل قليل
همم طيله المعطيه محصوره عند اللغويين فقط
واللغويون مجالهم عظيم ومهم لكنه لا يتصل
بالتقنيه والاعلام والوسائل فكيف نستطيع
ان نطلب من الجميع ان يتحدث ونحن لن نجود
له وهذا تحدي يجب ان نؤمن به ولذلك المجمع
يحاول ان يسد هذا الجانب بالمدونه بمركز
الذكاء بالمعجم المعاصر لكي نصل لكن
بالفعل همم في سياساتنا همم المقترحه تنص
على هذا الجانب وراي لها الحالي هو يجب ان
توفر بالسياسه معينه ليس بمعنى همم كل شيء
همم هذا غير صحيح وهمم ولا دقيقه وليس
دقيقه وانا طالب طالب وانما مطالب ان تكون
الهويه هي الاظهر باي صيغه تراها الجهه
المعنيه همم وجود الاسم اعلى او اكبر او
عدم السماح لي اسم وحيد ما لم تنظمه
اتفاقيه معينه ومعروف ان همم بعض الاشياء
التي يغيب عن همم احيانا بعض اللغويين ان
هناك تنظيم يكفر لهذا الامر ان نستخدم همم
اسم همم علامات تجاريه او اا او ما شابه
في هذا
الان برجعك اسف النقطه اللي قطعتك فيها
موضوع ال ال مسار السياسات
التخطيط والسياسات النوويه نعمل الان على
همم مؤشر اللغه العربيه نحن نقول ان ما لا
يقاس لا يمكن ان تقدم له البرامج كما يقول
همم المعنيون في في همم جوانب البناء وما
الى ذلك
همم هل تعلم انه لا يوجد جهه حاليا تستطيع
ان تقدم لك معلومه عن عدد همم خريجي اللغه
العربيه في همم دول عربيه معينه همم عدد
الرسائل المتخصصه في اللغه العربيه منذ
تاسيس المملكه العربيه غير مرصوده في
الدقه متناهيه همم كم عدد الخريجين في
الجامعه السعوديه في اللغه العربيه مقارنه
بالسنوات الماضيه مقارنه بمن توظف بمن وجد
له وظيفه همم اما الاسئله كبيره في ايضا
همم غير موجوده همم حد الزملاء يقول لم
يحسم لا نعلم معلومه دقيقه الى عدد الحروف
واقول له ان حتى ادت الحروف فيه من اليهود
29 او 28 ذلك نعمل في همم قطعه التخطيط
على بناء همم
نحن في مراحل الاخيره لاطلاقيها قاعده
بيانات ضخمه جدا همم سميناها عين العربيه
وهي قاعده همم لا تكتمل وانما تضل بحاجه
الى مزيد من الجهود للتوتر والتوتر عليها
اا وهذه القاعده سوف توصلنا الى مؤشر
اللغه العربيه كيف نستطيع في هذه الجلسه
ان نتكلم همم عن ارقام همم عن وضع اللغه
العربيه في وزاره الصحه وضع اللغه العربيه
في وزاره العدل وضع اللغه العربيه في
الاعلام كيف نستطيع طبعا نحن نعمل على هذا
الجانب بعد انتهاء هذه المقابله لنقول عدد
الكلمات التي قيلت من الشائع كذا عدد
الكلمات همم الفصيحه هكذا
المؤشر هذا نتوقع ان يكون في مطلع همم 23
همم 23 هتكون حافله ما شاء الله
هذا تحدي نقوله لان انا همم معنيون من
يتابعونه ويعمل معنا وعمل همم فريق من
الزمالك ايضا لدينا موضوعات طريفه ولكنها
مهمه اليها نحن نعمل على همم مجال وهو
الحالات الصحيه للغات كيف نستطيع ان نحكم
على اللغه العربيه الحاله الصحيه همم
لغتنا في في همم شبابها في همم
كهولتها كما يقال هل هي تعاني من امراض ما
نوع المرض
تعاني منها اللغه مقارنه باللغات الاخرى
نحن نؤمن بان اللغه العربيه في همم عنفوان
الشباب لسببين ما هو منطقي لسببين من يؤمن
ان لغته ضعيفه ينتج سائق ضعيفه
ومن يؤمن ان لغته قويه سوف ينتج سائر قويه
انت اذا قلت هذه لغه الشعوب الاسلاميه
ولغه
اساسيه لعدد من الدول العربيه ولغه الدوله
تعرف نفسها بان المملكه العربيه واللغه
همم طويل العمر يؤكد عليها والرؤيه سوف
يجب عليك ان تنجز همم ادوات قويه يجب تنجح
وما تنجح على موضوع
صحتها كيف انا اقول لك انا نؤمن انها في
في مستواها الرفيع هذا لا يعني ان لا
تعاني من
تحديات تحديات المستشفى في غيبوبه اللغه
العربيه بيني وبينك وبين المستمعون نحن
فيه يعني هناك من من يشاهد نعم هذا طبيعي
هذا جزء من ما ندرسه في التخطيط السياسه
لغويه
عندما اقول اللغه العربيه انا واياك ومن
يستمع الينا ويشاهدنا ومن منه معنا من
الزملاء في في هذا الاستديو
كل واحد منا سيتبادر اليه مفهوم بعضنا
سيكون اللغه العربيه انتم اللي تقولون
اقوم مدري ايش بكلام الفصيح وبعضهم يظن
انه عمه اللي متخصص اللغه العربيه في
النحو وكذا وبعضنا يظن اللغه العربيه
النحو والصرف كذا بعضنا يقول اللغه
العربيه قصدكم ضد تعليم اللغات الاجنبيه
وبعضهم اذا اذا جاء اللغه العربيه يظن
انها ضد الانميات وبعضهم يقول والله تعبان
مفهوم اللغه العربيه حين نقول نحن انها في
في نشاطها همم يختلف عن مفهوم من يرى ان
اللغه العربيه هي ان تمتلئ الشوارع الا
يوجد في الشوارع لغه اجنبيه فهو يكون
الاهميته همم وترى عندنا دراسه عن انقراض
اللغات ومفهوم انقراض اللغات
يستحيل ان تنقرضه ليس اللغه العربيه
دين او قوميه او دول متنوعه وهذه كلها
تتوفر تاريخي هذه كلها تتوفر في اللغه
العربيه لاقول يعني مجانا يعني فيها كتاب
سماويه دين قوميه العرب عمق تاريخي اللغه
اكبر من اللحظه التي نعيشه لذلك همم يقول
يعني اللغوي يقول ان اللغه
كذا او كذا همم يعني الذي نقوله يعني
ونحاول ان نقوله قناعه وليس انشاءا انه
اللغه العربيه عاشت حضارات ودول
وحروق
واجيال وثقافات قويه انا استطيع ان ارد لك
مجموعه كبيره من الشعر العصر الجاهلي او
عصر ما قبل الاسلام ماذا يعني تسميه
الجاهليه عليها سؤال لكن اصل ما قبل
الاسلام ما قبل الاسلام مجموعه منها
مجموعه منها ويقراها طالب في الابتدائيه
طبعا هذا يعني هذا موجود تحدي
صعب جدا
ومغامره تدخل اليها همم اللغه العربيه ان
لم تستدرجها فانها لكن ترى ايضا ببعض
المؤشرات على الحاله الصحيه بعض المؤشرات
اذا تكلمت عن عدد همم يعني لو همم
بعض المعلومات التي ربما تغير هذا المفهوم
اغلب الذين خدموا اللغه العربيه من
المعاصرين شباب دون 30 الذين يبتكرون
ادوات او تعريب او معالجات تقنيه للغه
العربيه في التقنيه بمجرد ما تكون اللغه
في معالجتها وخدمتها شباب هذه لغه حيه
حديث شيء مهم الثاني دوليا
اكثر من 500 جامعه في اندونيسيا
تدرس اللغه العربيه اكثر من 30,000 جهه
سواء على الجامعه او معهد
او او مقرر في الهند حسب تقرير القاضي
2006 اكثر من 45 قسم اكاديمي اكاديمي
لاقول ديني او كذا اكاديمي في الجامعات
الصينيه
في اللغه العربيه همم الدول التي بدات
تضيف للغه العربيه او يعني ترفع مستوى
اللغه العربيه من الدول العربيه متزايده
عدد عدد
المواساه التي تنشا همم
وغيره من مؤسسات معنيه باللغه العربيه همم
يتزايد همم مبادرات عجيبه
ومتنوعه هذا لا يتعارض مع انها تعاني من
همم تحديات نوعيه لكن تضل اللغه العربيه
همم لغه قويه همم يعني يدعمها مجموعه من
الخيارات احنا غلطان وباقي مسهرين برده
بدنا نعرف في مسار همم البرامج التعليميه
لدينا همم حزمه همم كبيره من البرامج همم
ولكن ساكون لك وحده التحدي امامي وليس
امامي انا وزملائي الكرام في في المجمع
همم نحن نتعاون مع همم هيئه تقويم التعليم
لاطلاق الاختبار الدولي للغه العربيه سوف
ان شاء الله همم
ونرجوا انه في في 23 سوف ينطلق وهذه
المستهدفات نحن ملتزمون بها مجموعه برامج
همم شرط اللي كان همم انطلقت اعمالنا في
همم
يعني الاعمال التي اشرت في ديسمبر الماضي
همم لكن المرحله الاولى منه فيه 23 ثم
تاتي المرحله الثانيه والثالثه المرحله
الاولى مختصه باختبار غير العرب ثم تاتي
الاختبارات للعرب ثم تاتي الاختبارات همم
الوظيفيه هذا اولا ثانيا نفتتح ان شاء
الله في همم نهايه هذه السنه همم معهد او
مركز لتعليم اللغه العربيه وتنطلق البرامج
التعليميه اظن على البرامج التعليميه
برامج للدبلوماسيين همم الدبلوماسيه همم
الذي يقيم في السعوديه همم احيانا لا
تتوفر له الفرصه ليتعلم اللغه العربيه الا
بطريقه همم بمستوى معين لكن الا يمكن ان
توفر هذه الفرصه هذه الفرصه عظيمه جدا سوف
نبدا ان شاء الله في ديسمبر المجموعه
الاولى التي تتعلم من الدبلوماسيين ايضا
في ديسمبر القادم همم تنطلق برامج تسمى
الانغماس هل هي مدارس مكثفه لمده شهرين ل
همم السياح وبعدها همم طلاب العالميين
وسوف تكون مستمره تنطلق حلوه
عنها شلون همم
نفس المعنى الذي يتبادل هو رمز كيف تستطيع
انك تغمس انسان في مجتمع نووي كامل همم
ياتي متعلم اللغه العربيه من استراليا
وكان يدرس اللغه العربيه ساعه في معهد
يذهب اليه بعد خروج تنتهي اللغه العربيه
ان ياتي الى المجتمع كل الحديث باللغه
العربيه همم يلتحق وفي المساء يلتحق ويشرح
وهذا تحدي صعب لكن ما اظن اليه سيبدا ان
شاء الله في جده نحن نحاول ان نتنوع
البرامج الدبلوماسي في الرياض للغماس في
جده البرنامج الصيفي مع مع جامعات عالميه
لسببين نبدا مع الجامعات العالميه ضلت
الجامعه العالميه ليس لديها خيار همم في
السعوديه الا خيار همم المعاهد التي تقوم
بجهود نوعه في وزاره التعليم لكنها لمده
سنه سنتين او سنه او اربع سنوات نحن سنقدم
قصيره لمده شهرين ياتي يدخل في هذا
البرنامج التعليمي ويعود اذا بدات البرامج
الريماس في ديسمبر ان شاء الله سوف تكون
همم مستمره ايضا نعمل على افتتاح المراكز
العالميه وهذه همم بعيد همم نتوقع ان انا
همم في همم ان شاء الله 25 سوف نكتمل همم
خمس مراكز عالميه لتعليم اللغه العربيه
همم امريكا همم نستهدف همم باريس الصين
والمانيا وهمم كازاخستان وهمم امريكا همم
الهند امريكا لعب برنامج مختلف ان شاء
الله نعمل عليه ويعلن عنه قريبا من ضمن
برامج همم التعليم اصدار همم منهاج او
منهج همم يقدم الثقافه السعوديه واللهجه
السعوديه الفصيحه ضل متعلم اللغه العربيه
في العالم يدرسون كل الحاجات
واقل لهم من يدرس او يعرف اللهجه السعوديه
انا لا اتكلم همم
السعوديه الصحيحه ايضا كل الذين يتعلمون
همم وللاسف بعض الذين يتعلمون حتى داخل
السعوديه همم ربما لا يتعلم همم بعض
المفردات يعني عن وادي حنيفه همم ربما
يدرس وادي كذا في الدوله الفلانيه ولا همم
المنهاج الذي نعمل عليه همم يوفر التعليم
الحديث يرتبط بالمعايير الدوليه همم لا
يمرر اجنده يعني همم دينيه او محتويات
بهذا الشكل يركز على الثقه في السعوديه
يحاول ان ان يعلم حتى المفردات السعوديه
هو همم
همم نسعى الى اطلاقه في معاهد المجمع
ومراكزه والتعاون مع جامعه السعوديه
لاعتماد ان شاء الله بدانا من الان
المفاهمات معاهد همم عالميه ليكون هذا
المقرر الرسمي لدينا طلب حاليا من همم دول
لتقديم منهج عام لجميع مدارسهم هذا المسار
همم الاخر في البرامج تعليميه من البرامج
التعليميه التي نعمل عليها عمل حديثا
اطلاق مجموعه من همم اندوات والدورات
والمجلات همم يعني واحد من من الاعمال همم
الذي يقع همم بالشرائع بين التخطيط
والتعليم في مجال ال- ال- همم المجلات
العلميه
نحن لا يوجد لدينا مجلات تنشر ابحث عن
الاختبارات او الحوسبه النوويه همم او ما
الى ذلك وهو ما نعمل عليه همم عملا
متصاعدا همم نفذنا الاسبوع الماضي الموضوع
همم في التخطيط والاسبوع الاسابيع القديمه
موضوع في التعليم في التخطيط مفهوم بسيط
جدا نحن تصلنا طلبات كثيره جدا من عده
مؤسسات بل ان المجمع واحد منها نبحث عن
مدقدق لغوي ما الجهه التي توفر لي مدقق
لغويا يستطيع ان يكون يمثل الجهه ولغه
الدوله ويكتب الخطابات ويحرر وسائل ويراجع
المحاضر ويكتب لاصحاب المعالي الوزراء
واصحاب السعاده والمسؤولين ويمثل اي مؤسسه
اي مؤسسه اتصلنا من شركات وتصلنا من
الوزارات وتصل لنا من هيئات هذه الطلبات
همم السؤال الصعب هل خريجه اللغه العربيه
يمتلك هذه الخبره هذا سؤال يطرحوا يفتحوا
جرحا ولا يفتحوا سؤانا كما يقال همم نحاول
في المجمع ان السود هذا همم برامج متنوعه
اصدار دليل سعودي لتوحيد الكتابه بدلا من
التفاوت وكل واحد يعني يعتمد منهج معينه
نحاول ان نعمل
مفاهمات معها لاطلاق برامج تغذي المهارات
اللغويه التي يحتاجها الناس يحتاجون الى
متحدث او اعلامي همم
لا نخرج اعلاميه لكن المهارات اللغويه
للاعلام من من يقدمها له هل الاعلام كليه
الاعلام او كليه اللغه العربيه همم المدقق
وما شابه من من يعمل عليها ايضا لدينا في
البرامج التعليميه همم لاول مره العالميه
المهنيه بالاختبارات وسوف همم قريبا بعد
ان عقد اجتماع الجهات السعوديه المهتمه
بهذا المجال الاسبوع الماضي همم عقدت همم
لدينا فاعليه همم الملتقى السعودي للجهات
المهنيه باللغه العربيه جمعنا الجهات
التعليميه وغير التعليميه للوصول الى
مرجعيه واحده ورؤيه واحده وعدم تكرار
الجهود والتنافس الداخلي نحن نقول دائما
اننا لن ننافس شركائنا وليس من مصلحتنا ان
منافس شركاؤنا نحن تقوى الجميع ونعمل معهم
اذا كان هناك جهود سعوديه نوعيه في مجال
علينا ان نتامها ويكون المجمع همم يعني
يتابع ومرجعيه وداعم لهذا ال- المجال همم
ايضا في برامج تعليميه اطلقنا سلسله وهي
ناشفه في اليوتيوب سلسله اللغه العربيه في
العالم نستضيف عالما او خبيرا من همم يعني
همم المثال يوضح كما يقال همم الحال همم
الندوه الاولى اللغه العربيه في كوريا همم
باحثه كوريا تتكلم عن تاريخ اللغه العربيه
في كوريا الندوه ثانيه اللغه العربيه في
بولندا باحثه بولنديه تتكلم عن اللغه
العربيه في بولندا بعد ذلك ايطاليا قريبا
سوف ينطلق همم كينيا وهكذا اللي محاوله
اعاده همم
وصف اللغه العربيه صحه العباره في العالم
لك وضعها من ابنائها وليس من الزاهر او
السائح او
في مشكله انت لك الله يسلمك تغريده في
خمسه يناير 2018 تقول كم عدد الجهات التي
تتخصص في ثقافه الطفل او لغتك وما هي دعوه
الى التامول ان ادعوك الى التامل احنا
كملنا الان كلها المبادرات ما جبت طاري
الطفل ولا خدمته ولا ربع مبادره لانك لم
تسال عن البرامج الثقافيه اه هذا اخر مساء
جاب الله
[ضحك]
ولكن للاسف سوف نستمر همم اللغه التي لا
يتحدث عن اطفال لغه التجهيل للموت ونحن
نقول ان اطفالنا الى الان في المملكه
العربيه السعوديه لغتهم يعني بالمجتماعيه
طيبه جدا لكن امامنا التحديات الجميله
سواء من همم الطلاب الذين تعلموا فقط في
المدارس العالميه او همم العائدون من
الابتعاث مع اهلهم
يجب ان نفكر جيدا لان المساله ليست قويه
فقط وانما ثقافيه هي ترتبط بهويه يعني لن
يكون السعودي سعوديه اذا كان يتكلم اللغه
ولا يعرف التفاصيل هويته وثقافاته وامثاله
وكلام جدته وكلام ااه يعني عن العم والخال
ولاهل والسواليف بل ان بعضهم وانا وقفت
على حاله من من هذه الحالات من يتعرض
للتنمر داخل اسرته وهذا شيء طبيعي ومؤلم
في الوقت نفسه ان يكون السعودي لا يتكلم
اللغه العربيه الا بلكنه همم هذا يعربه
حتى لتنمر لكنه ينزع شيء مطلق علينا جميعا
ننظر اليه هو ينزع جزء من من هو مشكلته
مين هذه مشكله الحقيقيه هي مشكله مشكله
الاكبر بان في كده شعور خفي
يبان على تصرفات الاب والام
اعتزازهم فخم بانه طفلهم ما يعرف
الانجليزي او طفلهم لغته الاساسيه هي هي
الانجليزيه راقي
يعني
قسم اللغه العربيه في الجامعه الاسلاميه
في الهند التي منحت طويله عمر الدكتوره
قسم اللغه العربيه ويشكر الجهود السعوديه
بعد التبسط قال لي سبقه وجهنا دعوه للسفر
العرب في مرحله معينه دون اذكر اسم الدوله
العزيزه همم
اللغه العربيه فجاء السفير عربي من دوله
عربيه
واراد ان يلقي كلمه على الطلاب الدراسات
العليا في الهند
المتخصصين باللغه العربيه فقال لهم لا
نتكلم باللغه العربيه لان اللغه
سوف اتكلم
لغه انجليزيه
المؤكد كما انت قلت انا وقعت بشيء اكبر من
هذا جانب فقلت له ببساطه انه لا يدخل
اللغه العربيه
مستواهم عالي جدا واراد ان ينجو فجاب هذا
المخرج المخرج جدا ان تتكلم كذا لكن هل
هناك من يشعر العوده الى سؤالك هل هناك من
يشعر ان اللغه همم
تعد مستوى معين هذا حتى في التخطيط اللغوي
صحيح هناك من ينظر هذا جانب بل لان بعضهم
ينظر الى اللهجات ان اللهجه الفلانيه ما
يتكلم هذه اللهجه هذا دليل انه بطبقه
معينه ومن يتكلم نحن نقول ان التنوع
اللغويه في المملكه العربيه السعوديه
الجميله الموجوده لدينا يجب ان يدرسها في
المجمع لا ان ندرسها ونعلمها انه لن يقبل
حتى حتى لن يقبل همم
اللهجه الفلانيه لكن نحن يجب ان ندرس في
الغالب ان اصولها وليس فيها اي اشكال همم
ولذلك لا تمثل طبقيه معينه تمثل الانتباه
تمثل حاره او قريه او مدينه او او منطقه
المثل الثاني همم استاذ خبير من همم
ميلاد همم عموم المغرب العربي حتى لو اسمي
الدوله كان يتكلم باللغه الفرنسيه
واخطا وعندما يخطئ باللغه الفرنسيه يعتذر
وعندما يتكلم باللغه العربيه ويخطى لا
يعلم انه اخطاء باللغه العربيه فهذه اسئله
تطرح تطرح علينا لنفكر هل اللغه تمثل
مستوى معين هل همم اذا تكلم اللغه
الانجليزيه الولد والبنت وكذا اا انه مطمن
انه كفلت له المستقبل همم الكريم كده همم
في سياقات معينه انت تحققت له انجازات
نبارك لك هذه الانجازات وهذه شيء يجب ان
يقدر لكن ان تنزع همم طفلا من جغرافيته
الثقافيه
وهويته همم السعوديه لم تكتفي همم بوزاره
الاعلام او هي همم هناك وزاره الماليه
رساله والرئيسه كيف تحافظ على الهويه
والمكون الرئيسي في الهويه هو اللغه
واللهجه والانتماء الى هذا الجحوش اللي
سويته للطفل في مسار الثقافي لا تستطيع
جهه واحده ولا جهات وانما يجب ان يكون
هناك مبادره اكبر الذي نعمل فيه الان
حاليا في اييي
سياق البرامج الثقافيه هو الاتي اولا في
عموم سياق البرامج الثقافيه نعمل فيه
سياقه البرامج الثقافيه على جائزه المجمع
واكتملت وتعلن ان شاء الله الفائزين وهي
على اربع مسارات همم تغير مفهوم همم
الاهتمام باللغه العربيه لم نوجهها
للعلماء من هذا المستوى انهم حتى في
التقنيه
والحوسبه وما الى ذلك كل من خدم اللغه
العربيه همم ستحصل على جائزه همم شركه
ربما او همم حوسب عليه ساعه لكن من خدم
اللغه العربيه يجب ان ان يقدره لان اللغه
العربيه كما نقول في البدايه
وهي مسؤوليه الجميع وليست مسؤوليه اللغويه
الجائزه ثانيا نعمل على همم معرضين للغه
العربيه نريد ان نخرج باللغه العربيه
ان تكون مستوى التواصل وان تكون النحو صرف
نريد ان تكون اللغه العربيه جديره بان
تزرع جدير بان تذهب همم المدارس بدلا من
تذهب فقط الى اسواق او العاب او همم
جهات ترفيهيه ان تذهب الى مجمع الملك
سلمان اللغه العربيه همم مجمع الملك سلمان
العالم اللغه العربيه لتزور المعرض ان
يزور الطفل اللغه ان نستطيع ان نقدم للطفل
همم لغته بطريقه مدهشه همم
لابد ان ينطلق المعرض في 23 ان شاء الله
وان يكون في مقره الحالي همم موقعا يزور
فيها الطفل همم اللغه العربيه وان يجد
اللغه العربيه ليست هي همم كتاب الاناشيد
او همم لغتي الجميله فقط وهي همم كتب
مقدره لكن انني جدا اللغه العربيه هي
اللعبه وان يجد اللغه العربيه هي جهاز وان
يجد اللغه العربيه هي خط اا يصير عليه وان
يجد شخصيات يعني في اللغه العربيه وان
يدخل الى الى حنجره يشاهد انا اصوات كيف
تتحركما الى ذلك في مسار اخر اطلقنا همم
تحدي همم للقاء للاطفال وهو تحدي همم
عالمي شاركت فيه اكثر همم مشاركه دي اكثر
من 25 دوله وفي منافسه قويه جدا وما زال
همم نشيطا واعلن الفائزين همم قبل يومين
اضافه الى اننا نعمل الان على مباره همم
الى سلم الصلاحيات المعتاد ل همم اطلاق
مبادره خاصه بالطفل لانه محزن جدا همم
السؤال الذي ذكرته هنا في همم 2018
لا يوجد لدينا في العالم العربي مؤسسات
تعنى بلغه الطفل ليس ثقافه الطفل ليس صحه
الطفل وما شابه اما مستويات اكثر حاجه من
الطفل اذا ذهبنا الى الطفل الاصم الطفل
ضعيف السمع
بعضهم يقع في منطقه كانه خارج الحياه
مؤلم جدا ان تجد طفل او كبيرا ولذلك عنه
نعمل فيه مسار برامج ثقافيه على مسار حول
تمكين اللغه العربيه او تمكين الصم وضعف
السمع من اللغه العربيه هل تعلم همم ان
هذا شيء عجيب انا يعني من خلال المزاوله
والجلوس اسمها مع متخصصين في هذا الجانب
ومجموعه من الصوم وضع السمع من تجاوزه هذه
المرحله يقولون همم ان همم اغلب همم
الصوره الذهنيه في المجتمعات العربيه تجاه
همم
ضعيف في السماء همم انها صوره همم انه همم
لديه مشكله في في همم ملكاته وتفكيره وهذا
همم خطا كبير جدا همم الفارق انه لم يسمع
اللغه التي يتحدث بها وبالتالي لنا لم
يبني التصورات التي همم بالتالي وسيله
التواصل معه مختلفه فالغته الاساسيه هي
لغه الاشاره اللغه الثانيه هي التي
يتعلمها همم لانه عربي
لابد ان تيسر له هذه الفرص ولابد ان
ناتي بقطاع السياسه مع التخطيط والسياسه
مع قطع الثقافه هل ينتج سياسه من لديه ابن
بعض الاسر لديه ابن او اكثر من لا يتعمل
لا يعلمون ان لغته الام هي لغه الاشاره
وليس العربيه وبالتالي ليس غرابيا وحشا
وانما لديه ملكات مختلفه ربما يمر بهذه
التجربه يعلم حساسيه هذا الجانب نعمل في
هذا المسار على همم مسار للصمم الطفل
التحدي للقاء والدينا برنامج ان شاء الله
همم يعني يرفع قريبا حول الطفل ومازلت
ادعوا المجموعه وجميع الجهات اللغويه عن
تخصص الذين مدونه همم نحاول انها همم
انجزنا المرحله منها همم كيف نستطيع ان
نقصد الكلمات الشائعه عند الاطفال كيف
نستطيع ان يديهم همم اضافه الى برنامج
التعليم عن بعد المدونه همم معمل الابتكار
المسلمين
تفاعليه للتعليم عن بعد كده نتكلم عن
الثقافه قبل الاخير همم وفراس اليوم لما
تقولي لغه عربيه الصوره دي هني عندي هي
بشت
اللغه العربيه هي لغه المناسبات روح الغي
خطاب اكتب
مستند رسمي بصيغه عقد البس البشت كاني
رايح لمناسبه الزواج ولا مناسبه التخرج
البس البشت هو للمناسبات الرسميه فقط ما
ادخل على اصدقائي في الاستراحه ما اطلع
اللي طلع العائليه المطعم بالبشت اطلع
بالثوب
الصوره الذهنيه اللي بنيت واللي اشعر انها
مستمره في الترسيخ هي انه اللغه العربيه
هي اللغه لغه البشت اللي نستخدمها في
مناسبه الرسميه فانتم اليوم لما تقولون
اللغه العربيه و خدمه اللغه العربيه
واللي على الثوب ولا ايش بالضبط اللغه
العربيه اللي تبوننا نمارسها ونستخدمها في
حياتنا بشكل طبيعي بتتكلم على جميع
المستويات عندما تريد ان تكتب العفو
استخدم اللغه التي تكتب في الارض وعندما
تريد ان نتكلم في مستوى اعلامي معين على
حسب المستوى هو انت بتكون في زملاء بل ان
حتى المفردات هذه معلومه من ضروره انك مع
اصدقائك يعني في الدائره الضيقه جدا تتبسط
حتى في بعض الكلمات التي ربما تكون ان لا
تقال وقد تقع في منطقه الخطا ان تكون في
جهه اخرى
ايضا ان اللغه مستويات وبالتالي الصوره
الذهنيه التي كراستها بعض المسلسلات ان
اللغه العربيه هي ان يتحدث العربي اللغه
العربيه في جميع الاشعه غير منطقيه طبعا
غير صحيحه لكن غير منطقيه لانه يتحدث فيه
خطبه الجمعه كما يتحدث مع زوجته قم يا بني
واحفظ هذا غير صحيح ولذلك حتى نحمي
زملائنا في مجمع القاهره انتشر انهم الذي
نفثوا به شاطر ومشطوره بينهما هكذا وهذا
غير صحيح هذه ترفع قبيلهم لكنها ترفع يمكن
احنا نقول انها موجوده عند مجموعه من
لغويين يرون ان اللواحي مستوى واحد ويجب
ان يرقى الجميع هذا غير صحيح وغير منطقي
نحن نقول ان اللغه العربيه مستويات وهي
طبيعيه عندما همم انا استاذ اللغه العربيه
والمفترض ان يكون في المجمع او في كليه
اللغه العربيه ويتكلم بمستوى معين لكن
عندما يتكلم مع همم ابنائي بمستوى معيا
عندما اتكلم مع اصدقائه بمستوى اخر بل انه
وهو استجابه طبيعيه حتى عندما تجلس مع غير
العرب المتحدثين باللغه العربيه يقولون
احيانا هل عندكم نفاق
فتكون انتم عندكم دفاع كل لغوي السفير همم
سربي قال لي ثم اعلنها لاحقا همم سفير به
في همم اليونسكو في مناسبه اليونسكو
هل انتم العرب لديكم نفاق لغوي شلون
تطالبوننا يقول غير العربي
غير العرب ان نتكلم بالفصيح وانتم تتكلمون
بالعاميه
ونحن نقول ان الصحيح ان اللغه مستويات
ولكل مستوى خطابه الخاص والطبيعيه تسولف
تختلف عن انك من الاشياء طريفه انني كنت
اتحدث مع زميل ونقول والله انا احن كلمه
جدتي الله يرحمها وهي تقول
كنت مستعده جامعي واللغه العربيه
[موسيقى]
انتشرت كانت تركز على دول حدث لها استعمار
فانتشرت عندنا واخذنا مفهوم معين ان
الاعميات خطر على العربيه وظننا ان ما
يقوله الاجداد
كبيره جدا
اساتذه المتعلم يؤكد ان اللغه العربيه
مستويات خاصه في المملكه العربيه السعوديه
لا تختلف كثيرا عن الفصيح الذي اختلافات
بسيطه ويجب ان ندرس الاهميه لاسباب عديده
نحن نبني مدور عن العاميه لا ندرس
الانميات حاليا لكننا ندرس مستوى من همم
او نعمل على ان يكون المنهاج حاملا لمستوى
من اللهجه همم الجميله هل فيه جهود همم
بهذا السؤال الاخير هل في جهود
لتعريب المحتوى اللي نستهلك احنا نستهلك
كمجتمع محتوى هائل باللغه الاجنبيه على
نتفليكس في السينما في المنصات المختلفه
يعني اتذكر من الاشياء الغريبه جدا
الاجازه كانت في في جنيف واحده من اهم
المدن في اوروبا اللي مزدحمه بالاجانب
واللي فيها اغلب المنظمات الدوليه همم
تتكلم على على مدينه افطرنا تكون محايل
مفترض اللغه الانجليزيه هي اللغه الاساس
فيها تخيل اننا نعاني عشان نلقى في
السينما
فيلم بالانجليزي تخيل مع ان افلام صناعه
امريكيه افلام الهوليود تيجي لفرنسا على
طول تتحول الدبلج الى اللغه الفرنسيه ثم
تعرض في السينما
يتصدقون علينا
بفيلمين في نهايه الاسبوع يوم السبت
والاحد هذه باللغه الانجليزيه لكم انتم من
الجنبه روحوا اسمعوها الاصل انك هتسمع
هتشوف الفيلم باللهجه او باللغه الفرنسيه
ديزني المدبلجه هي باللهجه المصريه همم
بعدين يوم مجتهد يحطوها
وبينها اطفالنا حادث
وهو يتكلم باللغه الفصحى بمبه في وش
الجهود اللي همم تقومون فيها
لتعريب المحتوى اللي نستهلك اليوم في
المنصات المحتوى الدوليه
هذا استاذ لبناني مختص في تعليم اللغه
العربيه غير العرب اييه مره
عسكريه في لبنان وهو يرويها
ليدرس
العسكريين اللغه العربيه فبدا يتكلم
بمستوى معين قالوا واحد موجود
في ذهنه المسلسلات المدبلجه باللغه
العربيه
انا انا اقول دائما اللغه المسؤوليه
للجميع
وليست وظيفته ولذلك علينا علينا
همم
تبع همم مؤشرات تضع مقاييس تطلق جوائز
تعمل في هذا الجانب لكن همم افضل همم
مصادر القوه هو الامل مع الافراد
والمؤسسات والجهاز مثل همم الشباب
المعانيين الان لدينا ان شاء الله وهي
يعني فرصه ان همم نعود الى بلاقي في
المجمع لنسرع العمل فيها
كيف تستطيع ان تطلق مبادره لدعم اللغه
العربيه لكن ليس بالضروره تعليم واولى
بالمستوى معين ترجمه الافلام هذه دون ان
يكون موظف عندك يعني مبادره سعوديه لترجمه
الافلام للعمل عليها همم لدينا مبادره
نعمل عليها الان لجمع محتوى الاغاني
لتكون مدونه معينه ونستطيع ان نرصد يعني
ما هي اشهر الكلمات وعلى على ذكر الاغاني
نحن الثقافه همم وسيله الاغنيه لتعلم
اللغه هي وسيله عالميه همم
همم في همم الاغنيه همم
في اللغه الاغنيه العربيه لتعلم همم اللغه
العربيه همم للاسف الحضور السعودي همم
ضعيف او شده الاغنيه ههه
بينما بينما تصل الى همم زوره مثلا
اندونيسيا وزورنا الهند وزورنا يعني صين
ونجد انهم يتعلمون احيانا مقررات السعوديه
فاذا درس الاغنيه تحولوا للاغاني ال- همم
المصريه والاغاني اللبنانيه والسوريه وغير
ذلك الاغنيه السعوديه غير موجوده اغنيه
واحده منتشره ودائعه جدا في اندونيسيا وهي
مقادير
همم رحمه الله وهذا يعيد ان اللغه مرتبطه
بالثقافه ويجب ان ان تعود اللغه العربيه
همم من همم
مسؤوليات اللغويه لتكون مسؤوليه الجميع
وهي دعوه في هذا البرنامج الكريم همم
وهمم تسمحني بهذه الدعوه العامه همم ان
المجمع همم يسعد همم يعني يكبر بي اصدقائه
وشركائه من الفرائض والمؤسسات واننا نؤمن
همم كما يقول طويل العمر الله يحفظه ان
اللغه مسؤوليه وتكليف علينا جميعا ونحن
نقدر الجهود النوعيه التي تبذل في همم
الوزارات جميعا والحياه نقدمها بصدق وليس
همم لكلاما انشائيا ونريد ان نتكلم معهم
ولذلك اقرب فرصه ان شاء الله سوف تقام بعد
اسابيع قليله همم لك بيننا وبين الجهات
السعوديه التي انتجت معاجم نريد ان ان
نتكلم معهم ل همم تمكين اللغه العربيه
وتعزيز استخدامها همم المؤكد
سعوديا يسمعوا مثل هذا الكلام في قراراته
مؤمن بخياره اللغوي نتفاوت في توصيف اللغه
العربيه نتفاوت في الحكم على اللغه
العربيه نتفاوت في طريقه استخدامها او ما
شابه لكنه يؤمن همم ان تاريخه اا
يعني هو عربي صرف وانه يتمنى لافادي
احفاده ان يتكلم اللغه العربيه ولن يبقى
للسعودي يعني همم
هويه لغويه اذا همم تغافل عن همم اللغه
العربيه اخر الكلمات هي نقول شكرا لك وهمم
كثر خيركم على الدعوه الكريمه الله يسلمك
بالتوفيق في عام 2023 المليء الثمار
بحلقه ثانيه ان شاء الله
الله يبارك فيك شكرا لكم
نواف العنزان خلف الكاميرات في تسجيل
الصوت عبد العزيز المسجد وفي التحرير انس
الخليل وفي الهندسه الصوتيه محمد الحسن
وفي الاسراف على الانتاج صالح با سلامه
احد منتجات شركه ثمانيه
[موسيقى]